So we can make sure
we really understand
what's happening in this little
iterative Fibonacci function
that I wrote, I'm going
to step through it
with a particular example.
So we're going to assume
that this function is
called with the argument 5.
So we want the fifth term
in the Fibonacci sequence
starting at where we're
indexing things starting at 0.
So the 0th term will
be really sometimes
what you would imagine
the first term to be.
We'll start at the 0th term.
So we're assuming that
Fibonacci of 5 is called.
So we want the fifth term
starting at the 0th term.
So we just want the fifth one.
And so when we go
into this program,
terms is defined as
this list right here
that just has two
elements, 0 and 1.
So what I've done here is,
I'm going to really focus
on what happens in this loop.
So as we enter into this
loop, the first time
that we enter into
this loop, terms
is referring to a list that
has just 0 and 1 in it.
And we did that because,
by definition, those
are the first two terms
of the Fibonacci sequence.
And then also entering
into the loop,
we define i as being equal to 2.
And we do that,
because we've already
defined the 0th term
and the first term.
And so now we want to,
as we enter the loop,
we want to add the second
term as we go into the loop.
And then we say, while i
is less than or equal to n.
Well, we already
know that n is 5.
So in the scope
of this function,
while we are running
it, the variable n is 5.
And so clearly i is
less than or equal to 5,
so we will run this
code right over here.
And we're appending to terms.
So we're going to
append something.
So entering into this clause,
this is what i, in terms,
look like.
But it looks like we're going
to append something to terms.
So terms is going to look like--
terms is going to be 0 and 1.
And then we're going
to add something.
We're going to add something
right over here to terms.
And what is that thing
we're going to add?
Well, we're going
to add whatever
this business over here is.
It seems complicated, but
when you break it down,
it actually doesn't
look too bad.
In this situation,
what is i minus 1?
Well, i is 2, so in this
situation, i minus 1
is going to be 1,
and i minus 2 is
going to be 0, as we go
through this iteration.
The first term in
terms, the first term,
so this is the 0th term.
This is the first term.
So the first term in
terms is literally a 1.
So this whole thing is 1.
And the 0th term in terms,
remember terms, the 0th term
in terms-- actually I
should write it this way.
The list is called terms.
The 0th term in terms-- this
is what term looks like right
now-- is going to be 0.
So this whole thing is
going to be 0, as well.
So it's 1 plus 0, which is 1.
And that's what we're
appending to terms.
So we're going to
append a 1 over here.
And then we say i is
equal to i plus 1.
Well i is, right
now, equal to 2.
So you're going to
add 2 plus 1 is 3.
And that's going to be
the new value for i.
And then we go back,
we loop back up
to the beginning
of the while loop.
And we say while i is
less than or equal to n.
Well, now i is a
little bit closer to n.
It's 3 now.
But it's still less
than or equal to 5.
So now we evaluate this again.
So once again,
entering into the loop,
terms now looks
like this-- 0, 1, 1.
I looks like this-- 3.
It's really the same values
we had exiting the loop.
And now we evaluate
right over here.
We're going to add
something to terms.
So terms right now is 0, 1, 1.
We're going to add
something to it.
And what is that something?
It's going to be the i
minus 1th term of terms.
So what's the i?
I over here is 3.
3 minus 1 is 2.
So this right over here
is now going to be 2.
So it's going to be the
second indexed term in terms.
So this is the 0th,
the first, the second.
So this over here is going to
evaluate to 1, plus i minus 2.
Well, i is now 3.
3 minus 2 is 1.
So plus the first term in terms.
This is the 0th term
and the first term.
So this is also going
to be a 1 over here.
This is going to
be 1 plus 1, or 2.
So we're going to
append a 2 to terms.
That's what this does over here.
And then we take whatever i was,
which is i, in this iteration,
i is 3, and we're
going to add 1 to it
and redefine i to be that.
So 3 plus 1 is 4.
And that's the new i.
Then we go again to the
beginning of the loop.
While i is less
than or equal to n.
Well, i is now 4.
n is is still 5.
4 is less than or equal to 5.
So we run this again.
And once again, we
need to figure out
what terms of i minus 1 are.
Let me write it over here, since
this is getting kind of messy.
Let me actually clear
this up, because I
want to be able to
read it clearly.
So let me clear this.
So now in this loop,
let's just think
about what-- so now, let
me write it over here.
Entering the loop
now, i is equal to 4--
I'm going to do that same orange
color-- entering into the loop
i is equal to 4.
And the terms has now been-- it
now has four elements in it--
0, 1, 1, and 2.
And now 4 is still less than
or equal to 5, so we do this,
and we have to figure out
what terms of i minus 1 is.
Well, now i minus 1 is 3, right?
4 minus 1 is 3, so
terms of-- not terms of.
I should say the third element
in terms is 0, 1, 2, 3.
So it's going to
be-- this whole thing
is going to be this
2 right over here.
So we're going to
take that 2-- I
know you can't read that--
we're going to take this 2,
and we're going to add it to
terms, the i minus 2th terms.
I is 4, 4 minus 2 is 2.
The second term in
terms is 0, 1, 2.
It's a 1.
It's this 1 right over here.
So we're adding this 2
plus this 1 to now get 3.
And we're taking-- so this whole
thing-- when you add it it's 3.
And we are appending
it to terms.
So terms was 0, 1, 1, 2.
But now we are appending
a 3 to the end of it.
We're appending a
3 to the end of it.
And then we're saying
i is equal to i plus 1.
I was 4, 4 plus 1 is 5, so
that is what i is equal to now.
It's equal to 5.
Then we go the
beginning of the loop.
i is now going to be equal to 5.
Terms-- let me write in that
same color for consistency--
terms are now 0, 1, 1, 2, and 3.
And then we say, well i is less
than or equal to n. n is 5.
Well, 5 is still less
than or equal to 5.
It's equal to 5, so
this still is true.
So we will execute this clause.
And now we have to figure
out-- let me clear this out
again-- now we have to figure
out what is terms of i, well,
what is the i minus
1th term in terms?
So now i is 5.
So it's 5 minus 1.
So it's the fourth
term in terms.
So 0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
So it is this term
right over here.
It is the 3.
So this over here is 3 now.
And then we have to
think about-- let
me do this in another
color-- and then we
have i minus 2. i is 5 now.
5 minus 2 is 3.
The third term in terms 0,
1, 2, 3 is this over here.
So this over here is 2.
So you evaluate
this-- you'll notice
we're just adding the last
two terms that we had so far.
This is how we build
our Fibonacci sequence.
And so 3 plus 2 is 5.
So we're going to append
the 5 to the end of terms.
So terms is going to be
0, 1, 1, 2, 3, and then
we are going to
append a 5 to it.
And then we say i is
equal to i plus 1.
So i is equal to 5 plus 1, or 6.
i is equal to 6 now.
We go to the
beginning of the loop,
and it says, while i is
less than or equal to n.
Well, now i is 6,
and n has been 5.
6 is not less than
or equal to 5.
So this is false, So we do
not-- we break out of the loop,
and we go to, I guess,
we stopped running it.
And then we go to return
the nth term in terms.
So remember n was 5.
So what's the fifth
term if we start at 0?
So this is the 0th term, first
term, second term, third term,
fourth term, fifth
term, and we are done.
And hopefully that gives
you an understanding
of why this worked.
And also a little bit of the
logic of how we wrote it.
It's literally building up
the Fibonacci sequence the way
you would expect to.
It started with the first
two terms by definition,
and then each time
we went to the loop,
and it added another
term and said,
hey, the new term is just going
to be the sum of the last term,
right now, and the
second to last term.
And add them together, and
then that will be the new term,
and you keep doing that.
You keep doing that until
you have, essentially,
until you've added
that nth term.